Christmas is just around the corner and
if you're looking for a gift idea for an
architect today's gift guide goes in
ascending order of how much you actually
care about that person so let's start
with gift guide idea number one the
first on the list is a morfolio trace
subscription you can either purchase
these for a couple months or a whole
year depending on how you want to go
about it personally I'd probably opt for
a whole year considering it's only about
30 or so a morfolio subscription is
something that most Architects will most
likely use if they have an iPad and they
have an apple pencil it is something
that I personally use every single day
as an architect and something that
always needs renewing and refreshing so
a one-year subscription to morpholia
trace is the perfect Baseline gift for
any architect number two on the list if
that architect doesn't have an iPad and
doesn't want to use more folio Trace to
level up their architectural skills then
potentially they might be looking at a
very useful moleskin book if you don't
know an A5 moleskin is the trademark of
any architect if you look around you
will say most Architects carrying around
these little black books now they're
super convenient you can take them
anywhere and because they're small
practical size and grid-like paper they
are one of the best books for Architects
if time is off the essence however we're
going to move on to number three number
three you need to check out the first
link in the description box it's going
to take you to my website where there
are a number of different digital
downloads these digital downloads are
perfect for anybody in the architecture
profession especially those just
starting out there is a variety of
different downloads from residential
process flowcharts all the way to
construction checklists for Architects
and designers so if you don't have time
to buy anything and you're looking at
this video a day before Christmas the
links are down there it'll be emailed
directly to you as soon as you finish
the checkout number four on this list is
for your clumsy Architects which also
includes me in case you didn't know
Architects barely sleep and when we do
we always need more so we basically live
on coffee if you have an architect bring
your life make sure you buy them a good
coffee cup but you you also have to make
sure that it is a spill proof coffee cup
because as Architects we're always
carrying around 100 different things and
the coffee tends to go everywhere so if
you have a spill proof lid then you're
100 good to go number five on this list
is the official Architects uniform now
if you haven't noticed already on this
channel I wear a black T-shirt every
single video there may be one or two
exceptions throughout the years I've
been posting but traditionally it is a
black T-shirt because that is the
architect's uniform so if you're looking
for the perfect black T-shirt make sure
you check out Cuts clothing now Cuts is
not sponsoring this video they haven't
sponsored anything on this channel for a
very very long time but I have worked
with them in the past so full disclosure
nonetheless I do believe in the brand I
do believe in the quality of their
branding and their t-shirts so if you
need a minimalistic perfect black
T-shirt again I'll drop a link down
below okay so you've made it more than
halfway so this means you actually care
about this person a little bit more than
just do random secret santa the top five
gifts in this architect's gift guide
start to get a little bit pricey number
six is the Logitech MX3 Mouse Architects
use their computer almost all day every
day so a good Mouse is going to be an
investment into their future and one of
the best things about Logitech mouse is
at Forever Scrolls and it's completely
quiet so even if they're working
non-stop it's not going to bug you if
you're sitting next to them like we do
here in this office and it is something
that they will truly appreciate number
seven on the list is a laser tape
measurer if you have no idea what a
laser tape measure is well you're
probably not an architect but every
architect needs one basically it's a
very simple tool you press one button
and it gives you a measurement it is
incredibly useful for anybody on site
all you need to do is go to your local
hardware store find a laser tape
measurer and pick up the best one you
can find now we're really getting pricey
so now I know you actually like this
person number eight on the list is the
one and only iPad Pro with the apple
pencil the iPad Pro paired with an apple
pencil is one of the best gifts you can
get to an architect because it allows
full flexibility in design Freedom
coordination office work basically
everything on the go it is my everyday
tool and it's something that I highly
recommend every architect have at their
disposal the last two on this list are
getting extremely pricey number nine is
a 3D printer now everybody's heard of 3D
printing but it continuously advances
every single year a good 3D printer is
able to create a series of 3D models for
Architects to explore their ideas and
one of the best things about a 3D
printer is you don't have to go and cut
hundreds of little shapes you can just
3D print this model overnight and
impress clients immediately so
personally I much prefer 3D printed
models over hand making models just
because of the time consuming nature of
the exercise now you've made it to
number 10 this is by far the most
expensive gift and by far the most
absurd gift you can get anybody so I
truly hope you really like this person
number 10 on this list is the Apple
Studio display it's the screen behind me
and it is screen in most of my tutorials
it is a screen of choice for Architects
for one very simple reason Architects
are often Drafting and designing in very
small details that means we're often
focusing on the smallest detail at the
smaller sizes on our screen if the
screen isn't clear if it isn't sharp
then you continuously get headaches
every single day so for me personally an
Apple Studio display provides you
longevity so you can work harder design
better and get less headaches it is an
extremely expensive gift it is an
Overkill in monitors but it is by far
crystal clear so that you'd never miss
even the finest lines anyway that is my
top 10 list of gifts for Architects
designers and students of the like if
you enjoyed this video make sure you
smash the Subscribe button down below if
you want to see more great architectural
content there's a playlist to the side
of me but that is all for me so like
always I'll see you next Monday